[Music]
there's a photo of damien dapps steel at
the season nine esl one pro league
finals
seasons they can be deadly at close
range zap's about to show us why
he's sitting at a monitor alone on the
main stage looking for
warren such a disaster it really is and
i mean again in terms of building
momentum and trying to get themselves
back in the game here
almost as if he's struggling with the
weight of a decision he had no control
over
right after the plant goes through and
now it's all on shocks and he just can't
even hold it
dapps will take him down in the weeks
leading up to the pro league finals
energy replaced
apps with stanislaw but with valve's
roster lock rules being what they are
stanislaw wasn't eligible to play nrg
had to feel that
in the picture dapps is alone on stage
practicing with a team that didn't even
want him
and preparing for a match that nobody
thought they could win
but if you find that kind of dedication
to the game surprising
then you haven't been paying attention
to dats over the last nine years
[Music]
dabs picked up source in 2006 as a
teenager and cut his teeth on a variety
of aim texture maps and gun game mods
before pub stomping his way through sibo
and cal
but as the collapse of cgs set na
esports back several years
dapps took a multi-year break his love
for the game only came back in college
with the release of cs go
the cgs collapsing was a massive setback
for the north american scene
it was a setback in a way that all of
our players of substance
no longer existed overnight um it gutted
the north american scene from a
professional circuit really
um so it pretty much casts a very dark
cloud over the future of north american
counter-strike and it took
it took years it took a you know it took
up basically until what 2013 2014 to
really
start getting going and even 2015. so i
mean it kind of took everything away for
almost
going on a decade between 2012 and 2014
he fell in with team dynamo and lunatic
two
online rosters that competed in civo and
esea events
dark he's going to be last man stunning
for ct ltk yet again in the driving
scene this round
dap's just he's cheating no doubt
so i'm sorry but after a promising third
fourth place finish at the face it and a
championship
daft naf shazam fugly and juvenile were
picked up by denial esports in september
and immediately bumped up against cloud9
and i buy power na's top teams
dabs played with that roster for seven
months two on denial and the rest with
team liquid
it was a crash course in leadership for
him he learned how to mold four
disparate personalities into a cohesive
unit
despite admirable domestic results zaps
liquid roster couldn't quite crack the
top eight internationally
and so just as quickly as they signed
with the organization dap snap and fugly
were
all gone two months later dapp signed
with conquest a canadian org that also
signed shazam
rush naf and ricks are they about to
pull it off here
conquest did walk into a little bit of a
stack up on this inner side and off
fallen will be caught out
and zaps is able to get four frags
despite their short time together they
managed to put up a few respectable
results
and dapps was developing a reputation
for being a solid player and a strong
igl
in particular his eye for scouting up
and coming talent made up for his
mechanics which
often a lag behind the other best
players in n a but by far the most
interesting thing about daps's time with
conquest was his introduction to
stanislaw who always seems to show up
just as something is about to go wrong
for him
santa's a great position and great
patience right now in behind jeremy hits
the shot
that's another one over the ledge that's
why they call it the headshot ledge
is down clock versus oh
man stanislaw getting another crowd on
their feet in real time
what was that after rick's left the team
stanislaw joined on before conquest
disbanded in december
then optic signed the roster in january
i've been trying to expand
the construct for the past like six
months and just recently
opportunities started to pop up left and
right out of nowhere an n a team became
available
these guys so the roster of optic gaming
is dapps who's our in-game leader
stanislaw and rush who are entry
fighters
naf who is our lurker and then myself
shazam the author
they got off to a hot start winning the
eleague road to vegas and a spot in the
inaugural e-league season
but after two disappointing showings
that the mlg columbus minor
and the major last chance qualifier
things changed very quickly
don't smile don't look at me i don't
know one thing
that one thing it's one thing on the
internet but it was like it was a
collective attitude like
when things are going wrong people can't
just like get older these comments go
funny like when you like die like you're
whining that's my fault
no it's not it's not no it's not
atmospheres
you start going at people too like okay
it is he's blaming me
everyone had a problem at one point like
yeah we got we got our game plan
we need to win a pistol yeah
to anyone paying attention a roster
change seemed inevitable and so dapps
convinced optic to take a chance on
mixwell an up-and-coming young player
from spain
dabson just vouched for mix well either
he also literally gave him a place to
stay
i watched pretty much all his games he's
ever played to make sure like i scouted
him hard
and the same play style persists in all
his games
and he's very aggressive goes for first
kills
and that's exactly what we wanted and he
was good at doing it and he
had the stats to back it up as well but
he's living at my house
i bought a new pc so that he can use my
old pc
and everything's gone well so far with
our new lineup like
we're having a good time and hopefully
it continues
well the roster shake-up provided some
short-term success things weren't
looking so great behind the scenes
okay just don't talk to me this stan's
really good player
right um but under my calling i think i
hindered him
because he's very good at calling
or doing things when it's something he
wants to do and i feel like when i was
telling him what to do or
maybe i was too structured in terms of
telling people what to do at times or i
didn't just let him do what he wanted to
i'm not sure but i think my calling
affected his play negatively
that was kind of thing is like did we
get rid of stan because like
he's not doing that well individually or
do we get rid of naf because
his communication at the time was really
bad and like sometimes he doesn't talk
as much but naf
is insane so it's like what do we do
here
roughly a month later after bombing out
of cologne optic dropped stanislaw for
tarik
another acquisition that dapps vouched
for you know he was very proactive about
always trying to make the team better
that's when we we reached out to tariq
or he reached out to tariq and that's
when we made
the switch happen and then a week later
optic drop
dapps for stanislaw so so we reverted
back
our decision you know to to keep
stanislaw
in the process uh tarek brought up a
couple of points
that that these guys kind of knew were
there what tariq
was used to was to an in-game leader
that
improvised more inside the game and
that's what
played more like an extra x-structure
based team where you know what to do
before the game
you already know what to do and you have
to take your own decision
every time and tariq was used to an
in-game leader that
tells you what to do all the time
obviously
you know dapps to me has been very very
helpful like i don't know where
where we would be as a as an
organization when it comes to
counter-strike
because he was very very helpful and
instrumental in in
finding the right players after building
a team that went on to win e-league
season two
and beating astralis for a 400 thousand
dollar prize
dapps was on the outside looking in and
looking for a new home
by the end of 2016 energy was looking to
rebuild giving dapps yet another
opportunity to start over
dabs convinced ptr to stay with the team
brought in rookies marky and breezy
and reunited with his longtime teammate
bugley like to get the energy team that
we have now it was a lot of like working
with people and trying to put it
together because it wasn't
just like it wasn't just put together
easily like i did
like pete wanted to find a different org
or team
um just to like get a fresh start i
guess i convinced like pete to stay and
then i convinced ugly to stay
convinced breezy to join yeah so sort of
like a lot of
inner workings to put it together 2017
and 2018 saw awful land results for nrg
and with that came a flurry of roster
moves at one point dapps even stepped
down to coach the team in hopes that it
will provide better results
within a month naps returned to the
active roster and continued to work with
players like cirque and ethan
more rookies that he convinced energy to
take on slowly but surely with
experience under their belt energy began
to turn their fortunes around
even climbing up to the fifth place
ranking in the world this could send nrg
packing once again for a couple of
rounds but dabs is here
and he finds two that could still be a
chance that's the bomb down there this
could actually happen
dabs the in-game lead is stepping up a
big live play doubts gonna be grabbing
the orb and actually knows that
it's a good effect with a double kill
coming out headshot reward still daps
doing the dirty there is a player to his
right might have a shot
does connect on to oscar that's a start
now left in a 1v2 situation bomb to be
planted 33 seconds but
the defense is on the way and now he
needs to stand tall and deliver
oh suck kirby goes down to suck it's
looking so good right now for the north
american team there's msl gone
and just found the left in the pit nrg
what a historic performance from them
ethan is gonna take the last kill 69.
somebody the last alive and for tyloo
it will be not anything close to what
they wanted it's a bitter pill to
swallow bintet's already called gg
nrg have walked all over these playoffs
dominant performance against gambit
yesterday in the semifinal arguably even
more so
against tyloo leave last one for him
coming into 2019 damps and nrg proved to
be a thorn in the sides of the world's
best
but never managed to make it over that
third fourth place hump
in an effort to break through the
ceiling they were pushing up against
energy decided to bench fugly and bring
in a talented player whom dapps knew
well
it's funny actually like my first event
i started with renegades i was checking
in at the airport and i had my only pair
of glasses and i had no rep like
oh whoa
the story dude holy [ __ ]
though the squads play improved it was
clear something still needed to change
and then rumors began to spread that
stannis law was back on the market
it was deja vu for dabs so dapps being
removed
is i have to say a move i hate for me
daps is one of the primary reasons that
nrg
even got to this position this is a
squad which aside from team liquid
stands above all the others within the
north american region
that's what dapps was able to craft
that's how he was able to navigate this
team
into a very very key position the
highest any team in his career had ever
been to
once again a roster shuffle involving
stanislaus tariq and dapps
saw dapps forced out of a team he helped
build but
of course before stanislaus could play
his first tournament with nrg
dapps had to play in the pro league
finals he set aside any pettiness and
played some pretty great counter-strike
they placed third fourth again but this
time they beat astralis the best team in
the world at the time
this is gonna be a rough one the x
factor is zip x rotating back over to
assist his teammate to demolish the
device himself
he's had a phenomenal event so far with
some other display he's been putting up
but he can't do much if he's just on his
lonesome a one versus free with no time
no kit
surely this is going to be round 16
going the way of nrg
as they will be able to pick it up and
that is the upset we did not expect to
see that we are witnessing
then roughly a week later the cycle
began again daft found a new home with
c9
uh hi i'm daps erdemian steel
um last team i played on was energy
cloud nine sort of came out of nowhere i
was contacted and they sort of let me
i didn't really get full control
instantly but they sort of just let me
pitch my idea what i thought a good
lineup would be so obviously
i sort of tried to build for cloud nine
when i build a team i try and
create a pool of people for like roles
and then over that course of time i sort
of like sift through all watch like
players demos and stuff and i'll sort of
try and figure out like if they're the
right role
c9 needed experience they needed a
leader and
they needed to rebuild and that's knows
a thing or two about that
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages